auf und davon mit der Mobiliar
Versicherungen und Vorsorge
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
du aber junge Junge
[Musik]
ich bin unterwegs im höheren
sehnsuchts
auch für mich
[Musik]
Schweizerinnen und Schweizer oder ihre
neue Heimat gefunden hat
[Musik]
Faszination ist vom Leben
Mitternacht und Polarlichter Natur ist
überwältin
das heißt auf Schwedisch ist Fischer
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
unerwarteten
[Musik]
morgen zu 10 Minuten wo es halt wirklich
machen
vor drei Jahren ist der Markus da einen
ausgewandert
en
also so viel Höhen du Friseur Fläche
das könnte ich gerne zahlen
wahrscheinlich die Schweiz ich habe ja
auch zwei Jahre in der Schweiz gelebt
bei Markus bevor wir ausgewandert sind
die Schweiz ist wunderschön also
landschaftlich ist es wirklich ein Traum
was halt das ist ein sehr eng
hier oben haben wir diesen Luxus das
eben wenig Menschen auf einer sehr
großen Fläche Leben sehr großen Fläche
Natur und wir sind uns auch bewusst dass
das ein Luxus ist
und was für ein Luxus wo Josie und der
Markus da Hand 60
[Musik]
sie nennt sich so gut wie möglich selber
versorgen willkommen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wie einfach ist es eigentlich sie zum
Sonos großes Grundstück finden weil man
auch hat
also das ist dann einfach zu Erfolg
berechnet dann
denke ich
sich so viel und es so viel Rückschritt
und da merkt man dann auch denke ich
wäre es wirklich will wer will uns
wandern und wer ist sich aber nicht ganz
sicher oder es minder wirklich
beide Personen
100% dahinterstuhl und wenn nur ein
Prozent dahin funktioniert nicht da gab
Bezirk kaputt oder einfach das ganze
klappen
einhändig ist alles immer ein bisschen
schwieriger
gar nicht eigentlich
erstaunlicherweise ich bin in der
mittelgroßen deutschen Stadt
aufgewachsen und wir haben immer in
Wohnungen gelebt und wir starten ja aber
ich habe mich nie wohl gefühlt
klar über die Jugendphase ist es
spannend und schön aber in Momenten wo
ich wenn ich zurückdenke und Momente gab
wo ich eben nicht mit Freunden unterwegs
war saß ich meistens am Fenster und habe
rausgeguckt und versucht irgendwo
Bäume zu sehen oder Vögel zu hören und
einfach nur geträumt aber ohne dass sie
mich mit dessen bewusst war ja das war
einfach immer schon die Sehnsucht nach
ein bisschen mehr Ruhe ich genieße
wirklich jeden Tag es klingt nicht nur
so klischeehaft sondern
angefangen
eins zwei drei und gewickelt habe ich
schon
bis später
soll ich mit denen anfangen
ihre hühnert sind für die Wahl der
Auswanderung
im Winter aber auch im Summen
kein Problem
eins zwei drei die zwei möhnet all die
Baghira ist zum allerersten Mal im Kanu
du kannst uns irgendwohin paddeln okay
sie scheinen recht entspannt zu sein
jetzt ist wieder spiegelglatt dass sie
mega schön super vagira
gut
es hängt
nicht jeder Hund ist ein Seehund
aber sie macht es nicht schlecht dafür
dass sie zum allerersten Mal das
Erlebnis hat Boot fahren die meisten
Hunde sind verunsichert weil kein Land
in Sicht Superpunkte
was jetzt sein kann was ich gerade merke
sie hat jetzt ein paar mal zu
aufgestoßen leise kann sein dass ihr
jetzt schlecht wird okay dann würde ich
aber jetzt langsam zurück
dass sie gar nicht erst in Stress kommt
oder im jetzt ist dieses gehen ist auch
immer Anzeichen für Stress und sie hat
das jetzt so gut gemacht dass ich denke
können wir beenden bevor sie ja es fängt
sie an
also jetzt
fahren wir zurückgeben
[Applaus]
hast du sie dann bereit
[Musik]
komme ich heute nach vorne kann es dir
aussteigen
super Buggy
hier unten sind alle und Baghira ist
hier unten und das ist so ein bisschen
so das Rudeln Mitglied ist jetzt nicht
vor Ort das ist ein krasser Ton
[Musik]
Stellplatz
und das Holz
sie ist schon Sport aber immer noch hell
im Sommer wird es nie dunkel
im Winter der Gegend
Polarlichter am Winterhimmel von Ivano
es faszinierend Spektakel
davon kriegt man nie genug egal wie oft
es kommt
[Musik]
märz vor dem Jahr
Josie macht Gästezimmer parat
es ist Hilfe aus der Schweiz dort mit
gutem Grund Josie ist hochschwanger im
achten Monat
das ist zum Beispiel das ist nicht mehr
so einfach bunter beugen und
so ganz kleine Alltagshandlung die
früher gar kein Problem waren sind jetzt
natürlich schwierig und ich vergessen
manchmal dass ich schwanger bin und dann
wollte ich mich schnell runter dann
merke ich oh nein langsam Glee muss
Josie für eine untersuchiges Spital das
bedeutet der obereis
drei Wochen wäre der Entbindungstermin
und wir oder das Kind ist noch nicht
gedreht also es liegt jetzt quasi
verkehrt rum im Bauch und ich muss jetzt
dreieinhalb Stunden wieder zum
Krankenhaus fahren dann versuchen wir
das noch mal zu drehen was wird von
außen versucht zu dass es gedreht wird
und wenn das nicht klappt dann wird
wahrscheinlich ein Kaiserschnitt geplant
wenn es Rind bitte gebohrt nicht richtig
liegt ist Risiko zu groß das auf der
langen Fahrt ist Spital ein bisschen
schief gehen
der Markus bereitet alles vor für eine
Hundeschlittentour mit zwei Schweizer
Gäste
[Musik]
also sobald die Leine noch ein gelöst
wird mir der Schlitten egal über Kappe
verlieren
[Musik]
einfach Ihnen
perfekt
so sieht man alles gut gegangen
noch der Fahrt
mit dem hundekek
Säcke
eigentlich jedes mal neidisch wenn ein
Schlitten rausgeht weil ich jetzt diese
Saison gar nicht fahren kann
wir dürfen gerne schon anfangen
Josie macht sich auf der wagenspital
Sauna ist in Finnland nicht nur zum
Schweizer Tor wir trinken
Frauen auch in der Sauna geboren wie sie
warm und halbwegs sterileisch
[Gelächter]
so jetzt
ungefähr
45 Minuten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo hallo
wie geht's dir gut danke
Sportler endlich zurück vor ihrem Spital
suchen alles gut gegangen
war ja verkehrt rum und jetzt ist es
gedreht
jetzt geht das Warten dass ich hatte
mich echt schon mit dem Kaiserschnitt
angefreundet gedanklich und zum geplante
Termin hinfahren und jetzt geht es
warten los
[Musik]
etwa 50% aller Geburten die halt von
hier kommen und nach romanie fahren die
haben die Geburt unterwegs das heißt
irgendwo auf dem Parkplatz
irgendwo im Schnee am Rand
ja aber jetzt wo es nicht mehr nicht
mehr verkehrt rumliegt denke ich hoffe
ich
[Musik]
wir haben sogar mit Ankündigung ins
Spital geschafft weil Aro zu spät
gekommen ist 12 Tage war er drüber am
Ende
womit keiner von uns gerechnet hat und
da mussten wir die Geburt einleiten
lassen das heißt sie haben dann Termin
gemacht und sind hingefahren zum
Krankenhaus ja und dann alles wie man
sich wünscht ja nicht ganz
okay
26 Stunden gegangen
und dann war es keine Ahnung ich hatte
keine Zeitgefühl aber gefühlt eine
Minute auf meiner Brust und dann haben
sie ihn gleich weggebracht auf die
Intensivstation weil er bei der Geburt
weil sie so anstrengend und schwierig
war hat er
Fruchtwasser geschluckt und auch
eingeatmet und hatte Wasser in der Lunge
und dann musste er gleich auf die Kinder
Intensivstation
okay und da hing ja dann an Schläuchen
und mit dem Gerät und sauerstoffschlauch
und zwar ja nicht der Anblick den man
sich wünscht als frisch gebackene Mutter
ja ach so wenn ihr jetzt für husgeburt
entschieden hättet oder welcher
sehr wahrscheinlich
gestorben und aber sehr in dieses
Vorfahren
je nachdem lebensgefährlich wäre und in
dem Fall wäre es genauso gesehen
300 Kilometer im Weg hier oben brauchst
du für vier Stunden im Winter war es ja
noch es war Lacke noch Schnee und dann
war noch ein Schneesturm an seiner
Geburt markus hatte vier Stunden für
einen Weg gebraucht also acht Stunden
Fahrt um mich zu besuchen quasi ja
[Musik]
hi ja
das neue Rudelmitglied hegelt sich halt
Hund
zwei Mal pro Jahr
weitermachen auf die andere Seite dann
gerade
jetzt verlieren dort
ganz verschieden ungefähr die Hälfte ist
aus zweiter Hand übernommen das heißt
von Tierschutzverein aus illegalen
zuchtstädten
ich entschuldige mich für Aska naja das
ist Liebe Welpen
zum Beispiel
der kommt von hier aus Iserlohn und der
ist von unserer Nachbarin quasi die
Straße runter und er war er hatte ein
gutes Leben war Familienhund war sechs
Jahre dort ist mit Kindern aufgewachsen
und die Familie hat sich dann
entschieden Hühner zu holen und Sumo hat
alle Hühner
gegrillt
und anschließend hat die Familie halt
entschieden dass sie lieber Hühner
wollen und hat den Hund dann weggegeben
dann gibt es halt andere Fälle wie zum
Beispiel primär die
ich rufe sie mal vielleicht kommt
wahrscheinlich ist sie irgendwo im
Auslauf jetzt gerade Mimi nie mehr
die war eben aus der Slowakei
ursprünglich und sie kommt aus solchen
illegalen Zuchtstätten also sie wurde
als Vermehrer Hündin missbraucht und
musste halt schon sehr früh oft Würfe
machen die Wetten wurden jedes Mal
weggenommen und dann wurde sie wieder
zwangsbefruchtet und das war wirklich so
ein Kellerverschlag in diesem Verschlag
hat sie eine Augenentzündung bekommen
und daraufhin ist die erblindet sie
spielen ja sie sieht ungefähr fünf
Prozent was unsere Tierärzte schätzen
aber ja umso mehr wundert es mich was
wenn ihr irgendwelche
Herkunft dass das Gericht so
funktioniert das braucht extrem viel
Aufmerksamkeit oder
definitiv das ist halt wenn man das so
sehen möchte als Nachteil der größte
Nachteil des Markus und ich einer von
uns muss immer hier sein also wir sind
halt die hauptbezugspersonen das heißt
wir könnten die Hunde jetzt nicht
einfach allein lassen und den Urlaub
fahren auf der Schnee heftiger
für uns fühlt es sich nicht so an weil
wir unseren Traumplatz gefunden haben
wir sind jetzt drei Jahre hier
aber ja langfristig ist es schon so dass
wir uns gerne wünschen würden dann wäre
dann auch mit Arom mal in die Ferien
können in die Schweiz können und die
Familie besuchen
wer bist du
yoloa hey Yolo heißt der Weihnachten auf
finnisch und sie ist am 24.12 auf die
Welt gekommen deswegen ist sie unser
Weihnachts und der Weihnachtsmann kommt
ja aus Finnland
das heißt übersetzt so viel wie
weihnachtsbock
der weihnachtsbock jeder Ort streitet
sich drum wo genau er herkommt aber er
ist von hier hey hey
für mich ist sie zum weiterreisen und
was denkt aber
was denkst Du also mehr Hund
relativ klein bleiben um den Hund auch
gerecht zu werden und sicher nicht so
viele Kinder
vielen Dank schön dass du da warst
[Musik]
ich fahre in richtig Schweden
erwartet mich ein Auswanderer
[Musik]
der Santa Claus schämt man ein
geschäftstüchtigen Kerli
im Sommer ist der tote Hose aber im
Winter standoristen
eine meiner Elfen hat mir geflüstert
dass du aus der Schweiz kommst und ich
spreche ein bisschen Deutsch bist du der
echte Weihnachtsmann
natürlich bin ich der echte du hast im
Fernsehen vermutlich anderer
Weihnachtsmänner gesehen aber die sind
Fake der Coca-Cola Weihnachtsmann zum
Beispiel macht
ich aber mache
pickdifferenz
in Finnisch auf Finnisch heißt du Yolo
Puky
juckel Santa classics
lesen dass du verheiratet hast nein nein
Miss Santa close und ich sind nur sehr
gute Freunde
sie sorgt für mich zum Frühstück macht
sie guten Haferbrei
sie macht eine Wäsche bürstet deinen
Bart ja genau
aber verheiratet seid ihr nicht
das ist sehr wichtig ja wir sind sehr
gute Freunde aber nicht verheiratet
Freunde okay
in Lappland
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
du aber junge Junge komm mal
du sind am kämpfen
und jetzt realisiere wieso sie so viel
Rentier auf einem Hufen hat der
Helikopter treibt
[Applaus]
5 Stunden unterwegs
der Fluss trennt die beiden Länder
gerade auf der anderen Seite liegt über
Dorner die Neuheit
in den hintersten
ganz langen Fahrt zum ersten Mal ist im
neuen
[Musik]
verdammt
Aisha blieb die ganz Nacht auf dem Baum
Max Henssler sie erst Kontakt mit
schwedener Strom da mit der Führer
[Musik]
Einsiedler Kanton Schweiz da hat Familie
Henssler vor ihrer Auswanderung
Projektleiter sehr viel geschafft bis zu
der komplette Erschöpfung
[Musik]
das ist alles deriane alles danke
Henssler startet nicht aus
[Musik]
hey hey
hast ja heute morgen
[Musik]
die große belauschtige Ortschaft und
Familie hält Folgen im zweiten Winter
vor ihrer Auswanderung wird stimmig
zwischen der Jasmin und dem Max immer
Rühl sie Trinity
ganze
und
ich habe
es ist scheiße
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Jasmin unterwegs
[Musik]
ist immer bestens geschlossen
vier Jahre ist das jetzt her
[Musik]
was ich Ideen
[Applaus]
wie immer stimmt aber nicht erstens
enthält ein anderer Hund und zweitens
fiel ich schneiden
Januar sind sie in euthal Kanton Schweiz
die
was ist der Grundsicherung
und Sport wäre und so machen
[Musik]
vorher machen wir aber noch ein Stopp
wie man Geschäftspartner schicken
wie alt ist Oskar 10 Jahre
ist das alt für ein Elch
im besten Alter
[Gelächter]
sie meinten ich sollte den Hut besser
abnehmen sonst momentan
in Schweden gibt es 300.000 freilebende
Elche aber man sieht sie nur sehr selten
[Gelächter]
der Ola Pension
[Musik]
Maxis Baby ist es Bauprojekt und zwar
denen auf der finnischen Seite vom Fluss
mitfahren
20 Blockhäuser sind die verschiedenen
Größen
es sind Fertighäuser
sobald wie möglich mir wird halbe Sturm
so groß in der Maxine
gute Frage
ja genau
wartet dann Falte
bauen ja also es ist Riesenprojekt
natürlich gibt es Menschen
[Musik]
Familie haben viel gemacht aber
natürlich auch ganz vieles geschafft und
muss
und das wird die gerne
gestellt
und mit diskutieren
dass man wieder mal Familie Ferien
machen und mich spüre die Zeit
auf die andere Richtung
für mich ein Kind sind
aber für sie ist da
[Musik]
in der Schweiz
und sie grüßen beides das probieren wir
so gut ist gut und
jetzt schon paar Monate
und ich glaube dass das schaffen ja
[Musik]
schon fast Mitternacht stimmig ist
unbeschreiblich
es ist viel schön zum Gogo Schlaf und
Ideen
[Musik]
ist der erste Tag vor der Markierung
die Rentier sind übrigens nicht mit dem
Heli Zement
der 2000 wir haben 2.200
Quadratkilometer Land das wir für die
Rentiere nutzen dürfen der Staat stellt
uns dieses Land zur Verfügung weil wir
als Samen traditionell mit rentieren
Arbeiten
man darf aber nicht zu viele davon
halten
wir rechnen mit einem Rentier pro
Quadratkilometer macht also 2200 Tiere
wenn du 4000 Rentiere hast dann ist das
sehr schlecht für die Natur und die
nächste Generation weil sie dann alles
wegfressen und nichts mehr für den
Winter übrig bleibt
der erste Schritt von der Markierung
die 14-Jährige Madeleine johannsen
Madeleine ist für das extra zweieinhalb
Stunden
hast du deine Rentiere gefunden oh ich
habe keine eigenen Tiere du hilfst
einfach mein Onkel hat Rentiere kannst
du dir vorstellen später selber Tiere zu
haben
ich habe vor einmal meine eigene Herde
zu haben aber das wird noch eine Weile
dauern
was ist das für ein Messer
dieses Messer hier benutzen wir für die
Markierungen im Ohr es ist klein und man
hält es so mit dem Daumen ein Song
manchmal schneidet man sich selber damit
weil es so scharf ist es hat einen guten
Griff
und du trägst einen traditionellen Sami
Gurt ja jeder ist anders das ist meiner
er ist hübsch
aber auch ziemlich teuer er kostet fast
100 Franken
okay
jetzt wird notiert Wähler
[Musik]
denn fängt die eigentliche Markierung
jeder jeder
am 4 am Morgen werden Fluss
[Musik]
das einzigartiges Bild und der niedrigen
Sabine erwartet mich mit ma und Kind am
Flussufer und das die gefühlte
Sabine
schwedischen Familie nein
will mehr als begegnete aber selbst
immer einfach Kumpels gesehen
und dann
zu machen
[Gelächter]
statt am Strand begleiten
[Musik]
das ist schön
aber jedes Mal gleich schön
zum Fische Münze
auf schwedisch
gefangen
[Musik]
je länger NYT orbisst umso größer wird
das wo offen dann es in Richard
[Musik]
das ist ohne scheiß Gefühl
dass überhaupt jemand etwas gefangen hat
[Musik]
Schicksal scheint für jedes labelwesen
und so hätte es auch Sabine unter Damme
zueinander geführt
beide hängt sie auf der gleiche Runde
fahren geschaffen
unsere Beziehung und gar nicht auf der
Suche nach einem neuen Partner
Sabine hätte es andersrum ihre süßli ist
nämlich ohne Heizung
ich hätte Mitleid mit Sabine weil sie in
ihrem eiskalten Häuschen sitzen musste
ohne Heizung
ich versuchte das Häuschen besser zu
isolieren und machte einen neuen Boden
rein
aber es war immer noch ein sehr sehr
kaltes Häuschen
wir redeten jeden Abend miteinander
redeten und hatten eine gute Zeit
du gabst mir Schweizer Schokolade fast
jeden Tag
du hast immer gesagt hier nimm ein wenig
Schokolade
[Gelächter]
so blöd ist das passiert und so und so
Spezies
paar Stunden später
auf verklettert und der Tobias
immer so im Dunkeln
und ehrlich gesagt ja aber mehr also so
ist
aber den haben wir einfach weg
entwickelt sich vielleicht
und so ist es ja auch hoch die beide
haben sich verliert und der Familie
gründet
[Musik]
so langsam sind
dem wir zum Schluss ein
zusammen mit den Rind macht sich Sabine
auf den Weg noch so Schelle
Astrid und der mathiskey
Sabine schaffe das Primarlehrerin
Natur und keine anderen
[Musik]
und
das ist also
es sind 20 Minuten Fahrt bis auf
socialle das Dorf hat Nummer 3
[Musik]
schwedisch auf Hochschulniveau studiere
Sabine kommst Du mal
trendlehrerin Sabine mit ihrem Vornamen
[Musik]
sogar Politiker
das ist das ist so normal da Mentalität
unkompliziert und ja mich so ein
bisschen
Schuhe
[Musik]
Fleisch und Kartoffeln das ist es in
etwa
aus der Schweiz
für Kinder aber auch für Sabine was
ist sie vermisst viele Produkte aus der
altenheimat aber noch mehr ihre Freunde
und Verwandte
einfach spontan
verbiegenen Hand und das geht einfach
nicht das ist immer alles über
digitale Welt und dann hätten noch aber
wenn wir jetzt im Sommer
in Arm nehmen
ich sie du bist
ist doch nicht Alter
hallo
ja also ja ich oh Gott gesehen aber es
ist ein bisschen aber
[Musik]
es ist leben aber abgeschnittenen Ort es
Leben nach der Natur Familie ist viel
Duss unterwegs heute
[Musik]
so
der alte
[Musik]
schwedische Hochland mit Bergen bis über
Baumgrenze
[Musik]
Sabine und ihre Familie machen da jedes
Jahr mehr tägige Wanderungen
[Musik]
das Tier will die Schönheit vom hochfell
Sabine und der Dame so begeistert
Verstoß
[Musik]
durch ganz schön
kennengelernt eigentlich wie soll beide
zu dem Hochfeld zugehalten ja
eigentlich schon dass wir sind beide der
Oper gelandet will mit beide Landschaft
der operieren
so Heimat oder das für dich inzwischen
schon
ich bin wirklich daheim
aber wenn ich so nur schon zwei Chur der
Buchstaben
stimmt das ich habe es nicht verstanden
ich denke ich bin ein ruhiger Typ
deshalb ist es auch nicht schwer für
Sabine mehr zu reden als ich
da muss man nicht viel reden aber
darüber denke ich nicht großen nach
aber schwedische wie heißt das Wort so
lagom Logo ja
das ist sehr schwedisch aber was
bedeutet es genau
das bedeutet einfach nicht zu viel und
nicht zu wenig
etwas so locker dazwischen
wir sind sehr ruhig und zurückhaltend
wir schreien niemanden an
wir Hupen nicht wir versuchen es easy zu
nehmen und wenn Deutschland solche
Sachen macht dann finden wir Schweden
das ist ein wenig too much
also warst du froh dass Sabine ruhige
schwedische Männer wie dich mag
ich denke schon so was in der Art ja ja
[Musik]
die entspannt die Ruhe wieder spiegelt
sich in einer Landschaft wo ihre
Schönheit aus dem Kragen aus dem
einfachen zieht
[Musik]
zwischen Schweden und Norwegen liegen
skandinavische Gebirge es ist länger als
der Alpen aber nur mehr 2500 Meter
sind Lofoten ein Inselgruppe vor der
norwegischen Küsten 9 Stunden weg mit
Auto unterwegs
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
Grenze zu Norwegen liegt gerade auf der
Passhöhe von
[Musik]
hey
hahaha
[Musik]
Ziel ist henningsware
nach der Fähre
[Musik]
am nordischen Meer
Bergen
[Musik]
krass wundert sie jetzt im Sommer viel
Touristen
[Musik]
Nummer 500 Menschen wohnen ganzjahres
schön Dich kennenzulernen Nelly an
diesem speziellen Tag ja ein sehr
spezieller Tag
wie fühlst du dich du heiratest heute
echt sehr wir haben eben darüber
gesprochen es ist ein spezieller Tag
aber irgendwie ist es auch ein normaler
Tag es fühlt sich natürlich an
selbstverständlich werde ich ihn heute
heiraten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wird am Anfang
einfach Ruhe Vergangenheit was es sogar
und hat er jedes Mal im Van außer dem
Auto klappt und hatte eigentlich ein
bisschen
sagte okay ich komme aus der Schweiz und
ich lebe im Bus
[Gelächter]
hier oben zeigt mir was für eine Person
du bist und weniger was du machst oder
wie viel Geld du hast oder was für eine
Ausbildung
ich dachte mir nicht viel dabei ich fand
den einfach sehr hübsch
[Gelächter]
es war alles sehr einfach wir haben
beide einen Hund wir gehen gerne wandern
wir haben gute Gespräche
wir treffen bin ich eingezogen
ja schon nach einer Woche und er ist
nicht wieder ausgezogen
sie zwei Jahre leben
vor dem prächtigen Hühnerstall selber
Zimmerer natürlich
verliert sie schafft in henningsware als
Lehrerin
dürfen wir dein Hochzeitskleid sehen ja
ja ja
Lorenzo hat mich schon im Kleid gesehen
der Schleier ist was besonderes
ja
die Haarspange habe ich von meiner
Großmutter sie ist vor zwei Jahren
gestorben
und der Schleier selber ist eigentlich
einfach ein altes Tischtuch aus dem
Brockenhaus
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
present for your wedding
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich habe gehört Käse sei wichtig
zumindest für ihn sehr wichtig
ich mag Käse auch für Lorenzo aber ist
sehr wichtiger es ist was spezielles mit
den Schweizer Käse
ja der norwegische es sieht leider
ziemlich unknösbar findet Lorenzo
und denn
[Musik]
och
das ist so ein wohliger Moment gerade
meine besten Freundinnen die mir die
Haare machen ja
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
abnehmen das ist kein heiliger Ort hier
oder nein das sind keine Heiligen Räume
hier
seid ihr bereit
ja liebes Brautpaar
Lorenzo ihr seid hier hergekommen um zu
heiraten
ich möchte euch die Bedeutsamkeit in
Erinnerung rufen wenn zwei Menschen sich
dazu entscheiden miteinander in eher zu
leben durch die Heirat würdet ihr eine
Einheit dennoch bleibt ihr zwei
unabhängige Menschen es gibt keinen
Widerspruch zwischen Liebe auf der einen
Seite und Freiheit auf der anderen liebe
bedeutet auch Respekt für den anderen zu
haben
Nelly Maria büh möchtest du Lorenzo von
Holzen der an deiner Seite steht zu
deinem Mann nehmen ja
dann frage ich dich Lorenzo von Holzen
möchtest du Nelly Maria wü die an deiner
Seite steht zu deiner Frau nehmen ja er
will
da ihr im Beisein von Zeugen euch
versprochen habt zusammen in der Ehe zu
leben erkläre ich euch hiermit zu Mann
und Frau
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die große Hochzeit mit allen Verwandten
ist ein immer Jahr in der Schweiz
[Musik]
am nächsten Morgen schlafe Nelly und
Lorenzo aus und ich erkunde Hennings
der schönste Fussballplatz von der Welt
seine Schönheit zeigt sich aber erst aus
der Luft so richtig
[Musik]
jetzt treffen wir eine Arbeit auf
Norwegen
darum geht sie es immer Video Tage
der Arbeitsplatz vor der Andrea Eugster
Lied 120 km weg vor den norwegischen
Küsten der Name von der Ölplattform
gülfax B
da schaffen dann Andrea jetzt zwei
Wochen am Stück ihres Zimmer hat sie in
dem Block dort
[Musik]
jeder hat einen
es ist extrem spannend warum eigentlich
14 Tage auf die Bohrinsel fliegt mit dem
Durchschnitt von der norwegischen
Bevölkerung
als instandhaltungsleiterin ist Andrea
Chefin von einer 12-köpfige Team aus
Mechaniker Elektriker und Automatiker
natürlich wichtig
ganz in Kombination mit irgendeiner
Explosion gehen ist extrem gefährlich
die 36 Jahre geschnitten
verantwortlich sondern auch für externe
Handwerker wofür Auftragsarbeiten auf
Plattformen
[Applaus]
kontrolliert und uns bessert
Güls
Firma equinoa wovor das parior noch
von Norwegen mit knapp 20.000
Mitarbeitende sie gehört zu zwei Drittel
im mordwegischen Staat dann kam Geld aus
der Öl-
[Musik]
Norwegen
Omas Öl haritz roh wird bis zu 3000
Meter weit
und quer durch den Boden
160 glüht wo zu jeder Sekunde
Andrea Eugster hat Geographie studiert
mit Schwerpunkt Meteorologie für ihres
Masterstudium auf Norwegen
nach ihrem Abschluss ist sie über das
Thema winterkraft zu equino Norco knapp
zwei Jahre später hat sie innerhalb vom
Unternehmen zu der fossile Energie
gewechselt
im
2012 wohne ich angefangen am Projekt
um das einfach ersetzen
gemacht und die ganze Aktion war mehr
Zeit mehr schafft du vererben
positiver darauf
extrem wichtig für Europa das die
sichere
[Musik]
was machst du eigentlich zwischen den
Mahlzeiten ich habe gerade fünf Pullover
gestrickt
[Musik]
Freizeitangebot auf der Bohrinsel ist
vielfaltig
U6
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mein Name ist Kalle und wir haben viel
Spaß in wülfax auf Wiedersehen
und wieder gut vor der Sache
langsam es ist
viel Nacht mit der viel zu wenig Schlaf
viel bis fünf Stunden
für mich
aber was soll's
signifikant im Moment
ziemlich doof
aber natürlich verglichen
verschiedene Risiko
Szenario eigentlich wo wir dann auch
immer wieder üben okay
hat Problem und hätte happy Landung oder
Explosionen wie hantieren
vom
Bereitschaftsteam oder Merchant series
würde mir Interesse
bereitschaftszentrale
garantiert und das wird regelmäßig
drillt das falls euch bis passiert das
alle wissend
[Musik]
[Applaus]
arbeitsfreie Tag geht es auf der
Ölplattform keine
super
alle anderen
[Musik]
gut und sind mehr als willkommene
Abwechslung noch zwei Wochen schaffen am
Stück mit wenig
[Gelächter]
schlafformen
richtig müde wird und da kommt
vielleicht besonders
[Musik]
ist der Heimat oder andrea ist ein
Helikopter plus einflugzeug Stund vor
der Plattform entfernt in reuken südlich
vor Oslo
da wohnt Andreas
[Musik]
wir trainieren nach Plan wenn sich
arbeitstechnisch einrichten lässt dann
versuchen wir es zusammen zu machen
vor vier Jahren gefunden am Ironman in
Südafrika der Triathlon Sport hätte sehr
wichtige platzi ihre Beziehung
ziemlich viel Stunden
im Schwimmbad beim Laufen ja einfach
schön
[Musik]
freie Woche macht Andrea nicht einfach
müde sie schaffen dem Homeoffice und
studiert management leadership im
Fernstudium
sie unter Günther entlang erfahren
bezirka oder letzte Weihnacht müssen
die Sicherheit die ich hatte in
Österreich mit dem mit dem Job und allem
das setzt da dann doch wir waren zwei
Jahre zusammen
wenn das Gefühl stimmt muss man Job
bekommt man wieder
ich hatte das Gefühl wenn ich es nicht
probiere könnte ich es bereuen im hinten
nach
und so habe ich nichts zu bereuen
jetzt wird spannend
nach der Auswanderung
[Musik]
die beiden das Paar Woche zieht bis zu
den
norwegische Fjord
[Musik]
mit der Hochzeitstanz
wir würden uns freuen
[Gelächter]
völlig klar mein Sohn
ich stelle fest im höheren
ich bin immer noch im schönen
henningsware auf der Lofoten
im Sommer ist der verschlafene
[Musik]
ohne die sogenannte private Fabriken
werden Nelly und Lorenzo nicht
heißt holzware und dir eins
dahergestellt aber auch Lebertran ist
okay und November
ich werde gesehen was der Lorenzo alles
geschrien
auf dem Weg
zum Lebertran machen
nachdem Sie den Fisch gefangen hatten
versuchten sie so viel wie möglich davon
zu verwenden auch die Leber sie kochten
sie in diesen Bottichen aus man sagt
dass man jeden Monat in welchem man er
vorkommt Lebertran nehmen soll um gesund
zu bleiben
und die Runden
mega cool
erinnerst du dich daran wie Lorenzo hier
auftauchte ja
ich sah ein Auto kommen und ein Hund
sprang heraus wer ist denn das
dann fragte Lorenzo ob wir Arbeit für
einen Schreiner hätten
und wir sagten ja tatsächlich wir haben
einen Job für dich
er kam zum richtigen Zeitpunkt
er hätte auch Hotelzimmer
am Anfang hätte alles mit Handwerkzeug
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Lorenzo und Nelly nennt sich ein
traumhaften
[Musik]
für den Moment für die nächsten paar
Jahren
also du denkst daran vielleicht auch mal
in der Schweiz zu leben
ich würde sehr gerne ein zwei Jahre in
der Schweiz leben um die Sprache zu
lernen wenigstens so viel dass ich
besser mit Lorenzos Mutter reden könnte
das wäre großartig
und ich liebe die Schweiz so schön gutes
Essen nette Leute alles ist so hübsch
und das Gras ist perfekt geschnitten
[Gelächter]
und eine eigene Familie habt ihr Pläne
oder Wünsche
ja
also wir möchten Kinder und Familie es
wäre schön sein eigenes kleines Rudel zu
haben
was die frisch Vermählten schwanger
eigentlich wollte er die Schweiz nur für
drei Monate verlassen ja und jetzt
sitzen wir hier
[Gelächter]
ich glaube das geht ganz vielen Menschen
so
ich kenne da noch so eine Geschichte
wo man jetzt treffen
Land
mittlerweile
sondern er ist ich glaube eigentlich
Lorenzo so etwas wie die persönlichen
Schweizer skandinavienten
gut gefüllte Kassel mit den Finnland
der ganze Stolz vom 350-jährigen Peter
Dörig
seid macht kein zu rezenten
[Applaus]
direkt noch durchstrecken
und
bin dann erst nachher gelaufen
heute Peter wieder riesig
für vier Millionen Euro hat
mit Restaurant und Shop
pro Jahr verarbeitete Peter 600.000
Liter Milch
es ist es Familienunternehmen wurde
Peter zusammen mit seiner Frau Jenny
führt
moin
jenny hat für Glaserei ihre prüf als
Ingenieurin für traktor-motoren Aufgaben
die
älteste Tochter Ida hilft auch mit dem
Betrieb
und
ja so ich mache da
Instagram und so zurück für Kresse
eigentlich mit Traum zum Dada eher
Gewinden übernehmen
so wie es Papa jetzt gemacht hat
der Peter im Alter von
ganz andere treuencar aus der Betrieb
vom Vater zu
der Peter ist schon immer ein Abenteuer
gesehen
Schweiz
und mit Freunden die Schweiz mit
kollegischen Fernsehen
und da ich dann halt dafür
ermöglichkeiten
Finnland fahre nach Zentralasien
Strecken
ja da ist und da ist ja keine andere
Schweiz
dir zieht es sind für die er schlief
hinter Peters
[Musik]
heute Peter aus fürsorglicher Vater in
der
irgendwo abzahlen
[Musik]
der Peter ist
in Sasse Mala Finnland
[Musik]
er wohnt mit dem Wald
Jenny entworfen hat und wo doch stark an
es Schweizer Chalet
[Musik]
zum Peters im Sitz gehört auch nach
altenholzhüser drauf
ist
der Ort übersetzt Huus im Wald
ganz der Finnen gehört für den Peter
noch 26 Jahre im Land Sauna auch im
Sommer dazu
[Musik]
wichtige Entscheidungen
Glück vom Peter Dörig
aber m Peters war ganz anders verlaufen
war doch nicht da Schicksalsschlag
passiert vor 20 Jahren offen
wo ich bin Peter
überwachen
da ist es im Jahr
altem aber irgendwie der Husten
ich fühle mich wie im finnischen
Ballenberg
eigentlich der Grund dass du deins
Finnland bleiben
und den Stefan
quasi verschollen verschollen in
Kasachstan und denen passiert
Monate lang und schlussendler bis man
ein kleiner haihof meierfeld bringen ist
halt sind halt die Ohren
[Musik]
Geschichte vom Peters im Kollege Reto
ist vor 20 Jahren
aufgerollt wurde
der Peter macht sich in dem Film nochmal
oft Spuren vor seinem verschwundene
Freund die beide Handy ganz große Touren
gemacht wo Finnlands
[Musik]
jedes Mal wenn man von irgendwo
highwasser gegangen sind oder so einmal
auf der Weltkarte nie zeichnet wo man
direkt fahren sind
kann ich da etwas letzte Mal gesehen und
sinifad ist es heute zu ergangen um
minifahrte
Schweizer
verschwunden ist der Reto und seine LKW
sind wir vom Erdboden verschluckt nach
zwei Monate findet
aber ohne Anhänger
gesucht wird Herr Reto Bentley
verschollen seit dem 24 Oktober 1997
das letzte Mal lebend See worden ist
ja noch ein Verschwinden vom Reto
tauchten
Spur führt zu zwei Russen wo sich
gegenseitig beschuldigen
vieles bliebt unklar eine von der beiden
Verhafteten zeigt der Polizei
schlussendlich wo im Reto sie Körper
begraben liegt
[Musik]
die letzte Zwiebel noch vier Jahre und
Gewissheit
mit ihm da
oben bleiben
und du im 96 im Frühling
zum go
und dann ist der Moment wirklich hoch wo
man da haben wir schon überlegen was
erzähle oder was in den älteren und ja
also wenn da nicht passiert wäre sie ist
Schicksal dann wärst du nicht so lange
da bleiben
gelernt ihr hättet die vier töchteren
oder überleister
oder Schicksal und beim Reto ist jetzt
mehr Schicksal gesehen
[Musik]
also wenn die jung bist
jung frei und will einen schönen aus
[Musik]
aber noch ein Verlust vom reden
hey hallo
sind halt in der Schweiz und ja sieht
lehan ist
einfach immer denken ich würde mit mir
Familie da in Finnland irgendeinen
Sprachen dass man Gründe
ich will in der Schule mit Österreicher
um einfacher reden
gelernt der Peter ist sofort für und
Flamme aber hat ein Freund gehabt
jetzt kommt's aus also ich habe Chöre
auf der Schweiz
das richtige ist und dann ist sie an der
Tankstelle im dorfisch immer am
tankensee und hätte
wenn jetzt da eine virana fahren mit dem
TÜV würde und mit dem Weg und der Monat
später bin mit dem TV
vom Lastwagen
[Gelächter]
skandinavisches Sprichwort Zeit es gibt
Kreis schlechtes Wetter es gibt nur
Zucchini Flamingos
ich bin Teil vom speziellen
wird der riesige Flamingo zum See
braucht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
vor allem
Finnland Schweden und Norwegen finden
das sind das speziell Leute
[Gelächter]
miteinander essen machen in Schweizer
Ali und lassen die immer zur Schweiz
[Gelächter]
Spruch das Glück und nicht wenn man
sucht sondern wenn es lebt
besonders gut zum fünften Mal
hintereinander
[Musik]
ich bin richtig beschenkt mit dem ganzen
Blumenstrauß und Geschichte ich habe
Faszination für die Landschaft oben
für Sie das Richtige Lebens
ihr erinnert euch von der Andrea und dem
Günther während Andrea schon im Gälisch
auf der Ölplattform
jetzt erleben
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
kennt mich noch
nein
Anspannung etwas an
[Musik]
ich muss Unterschriften
und jetzt müssen
[Musik]
aber
warum frage ich Sie Andrea Nina euster
sind sie wählt gegen Türkei in einer
eher auf der Grundlage von zusammen sein
und Respekt zu leben
sind sie gewählt Andrea altstädt
zusammen sein und gegenseitigen Respekt
zu leben ja
tauschen Sie bitte die Regeln aus
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Hochzeitstanz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und so schön ganze Zeit
so offen und herzlich eindüst Menschen
[Musik]
sie alle sind Huf und davor und Aachen
auf und davon mit der Mobiliar
Versicherungen und Vorsorge